Death. It’s an excellent topic of conversation
because it’s so relatable - After all,
it’s bound to happen to all of us. Well,
except Dr. Bright. Sorry, Jack. The leading
causes of death for most normal people are heart
disease, cancer, accidents, and strokes, but for
people working at the SCP Foundation - or those
unlucky enough to have brushes with the anomalous
in civilian life - the wheel of misfortune has
plenty more options for your inevitable demise.
We’re not talking about boring deaths like
being eaten by a giant killer reptile or
being disintegrated on an atomic level by a giant,
winged guardian with a sword hotter than the sun.
The truly sticky ends we’re talking about
today will make weak-sauce fatalities like that
look like passing away peacefully
in your sleep. Prepare for a big,
warm spoonful of existential terror, because this
is the worst ways to die - SCP Foundation edition!
Let’s kick off this carnival of death with an
old friend of ours: Uncle Larry himself, SCP-106,
also known as The Old Man. This SCP
celebrity is infamous for two things:
His ability to walk through solid objects,
and his absolute adoration for causing pain.
Seriously, this is a guy who loves
torturing people so much that he
has his own pocket dimension specifically
tailored for the grisly task. That’s why,
if you fall into his greasy black claws, you’ve
got an utterly nightmarish death in store for you.
Expect to be tortured and mutilated
over an extremely long period of time.
His greatest hits include pulling out your teeth,
shoving his fingers or even arms into your body,
and of course, melting you. Thankfully, a lot
of the finer details of what this freak does
to his victims are either redacted or not
recorded - probably for the sake of all of
our collective sanities. But for some context,
one of his recovered victims looked like this.
The worst part? He was still alive
when that photo was taken. Sleep tight!
Or, alternatively, don’t. Because
if you have SCP-966 on your tail,
you won’t be sleeping at all. These nasty
little gremlins are called the Sleep Killers,
which is somewhat ironic because, as part of
their protracted stalking and hunting period,
they disable their victim’s ability to sleep.
Picture that: Invisible monsters keeping you
awake forever, leading to a period of deadly
insomnia. You’ll become tired, but you’ll never
know rest. You’ll start hallucinating. You’ll get
weak. Everyone around you will just think you’re
very sick, and they’ll probably recommend
everything from Nyquil to Valerian root.
But none of it will help. Nothing will help.
Technically, you’re a walking corpse already. And
just when you think it can’t get any worse, when
your mind has practically been turned to soup in
your head by the sleep deprivation...That’s when
the Sleep Killers will finally strike. They’ll
attack, tear you to pieces, and eat you alive.
You will have gone through your own personal hell,
and nobody will ever know what happened to you.
Say, speaking of personal hells and long,
traumatic deaths, let’s mosey on over to our next
horrific method of spin-kicking off the mortal
coil: SCP-439, also known as the Bone Hive. If
you’re familiar with this nasty customer already,
then I’m sorry you’re about to go through this
nightmare again, but for the rest of you, this
SCP is a species of tiny, silver earwigs with some
truly unique breeding and nesting habits. Namely,
they make their nests out of living people.
The queen of their colonies will crawl
into your body while you’re sleeping,
leading to what seems at first like a nasty
cough and some bodily aches and pains. These
soon become so agonizing that you’re paralyzed.
You lock yourself into a small, dark place,
at which point the rapidly breeding earwigs inside
you will start to convert your body into a huge,
calcium hive. They’ll turn your internal organs
into breeding centers and food sources. You’ll be
alive through all of this, too. Why? Because your
living body acts as an internal heating system.
You will die in the end, if that’s
any consolation...of starvation.
Wow. What a bummer, right? I think we could
all use a good laugh after that last one.
Thankfully, we’ve got SCP-2030, also known as
Laugh is Fun, to deliver some levity into this
otherwise dire situation. 2030 is probably
the ultimate hardcore hidden camera show,
where the terrifying anomalous pranks often lead
to their victims meeting gruesome ends. While
their victims and surrounding bystanders often
find these nightmarish deaths weirdly funny,
the ends that 2030 dishes out
are enough to turn your stomach.
Here are a few examples for you, just to whet
- or permanently destroy - your appetite:
An old woman feeding pigeons in the park
had a hundred pigeons fly down her throat,
bursting her stomach open. A man was flayed alive
and had his skin filled with live squirrels.
A woman was attacked by a lump of flesh shaped
like an amalgamation of Margaret Thatchers,
which then shoved its tongue down her throat,
causing her body to be transformed into a
collection of Margaret Thatcher faces too.
And the scariest thing is that all of these
victims technically died by more normal means
already. That’s right: Everyone who stars in
this twisted show is already dead before they
ever make their appearance. Their restless
souls drawn into the nightmare of SCP-2030,
where they’re killed again in even worse ways.
Phew, baby, that was unpleasant.
Let’s instead talk about The Baby.
No, not Da Baby, we’re talking
about SCP-734, The Baby. Let’s go!
This cute little baby seems innocent enough,
and in terms of his personality, he is. However,
the bodily fluids of this baby can give you
a truly sickening death. If you come into
contact with the baby’s fluids, you’ll begin to
experience what first seems like an aggressive
skin condition - pain, itching, and redness. This
will then lead to even more unpleasant and painful
skin flaking, which will soon begin to expand
over your body, eating away at you more and more.
The flaking will get wider and deeper. Your
organs and bones will start to disintegrate.
Little by little, you’ll painfully
fall to pieces over a number of hours.
By the time you’re dead, you’ll look
like a big pile of bloody dandruff.
Needless to say, it’s incredibly unpleasant.
Speaking of big, unpleasant piles, let’s talk
about the horrifying death you can get courtesy
of SCP-162, also known by the appropriately
ominous name: The Ball of Sharp. This thing is
so deadly that it’s one of the many SCPs that the
Foundation has tried to use to terminate SCP-682.
It’s an eight-foot-tall pile of fish hooks,
fish line, needles, scissors, and almost every
other sharp, pointy object you can imagine.
You’ve heard of a needle in a haystack? Well,
meet the needle stack, where the hay is
you! And scariest of all, this SCP has the
cognitohazardous effect of brainwashing you
into wanting to jump into its spiky embrace.
And if you jump into the Ball of Sharp...Well,
what the heck do you think happens? You’ll get
poked and stabbed and cut horrifically. And
because of the cognitohazardous effects, you’ll
alternate between complaining about horrific
pain, to talking about how much you love it,
and would like to be left alone
with the Ball. And of course,
in the end, you’ll either bleed to death
or die of extreme body trauma. Yay!
Y’know, if you really think about it, the Ball of
Sharp seems a little like an avant-garde modern
art piece. Perhaps it’s a commentary on how
much it’d suck to get thrown into a giant ball
of pointy objects. Speaking of art and things that
suck, it’d really suck to be murdered by SCP-1155,
the Predatory Street Art. This horrific,
two-dimensional predator is a piece of
evil graffiti that preys on solitary victims
who happen to stray too close to its grasp.
And the Predatory Street Art is a monster so
gratuitously violent, it’d probably get along
really well with Uncle Larry. It won’t just
kill and eat you like a standard predator,
it’ll kill you, chop you up, and put your body
parts in its gory cupboard in order to eat you
as a midnight snack later. And while this
is a gruesome way to go, it’s still nothing
compared to the sheer, mind-bending horror that
getting killed by the next anomaly will bring.
Christmas only comes once a year, and
SCP-4666, also known as The Yule Man,
will make you extremely grateful for that. This
living nightmare of an anomaly only operates over
a twelve-day period during the Christmas season,
and if you happen to be on this sadistic Santa’s
naughty list, you’re probably in for a horrible
fate that is literally beyond what we’re able to
fully describe here. To give you some perspective:
If you’re lucky, he’ll just murder you and your
entire family in one evening - normally
using torture, mutilation, and cannibalism.
And if you’re unlucky and also underage, then
the Yule Man will take you down to his workshop,
where you’ll act as his slave, and spend
the rest of your life making morbid toys.
And then, if you’re the luckiest among
the unlucky, he’ll take you aside and
eat you when he’s feeling hungry. If not,
he’ll work you until your body breaks,
then force your fellow workers to convert
you into a toy while you’re still alive.
That’s right: If you’re not fit enough to keep
slaving away and make the toys, you’ll literally
be made into the toys. Needless to say, you
certainly won’t be having a Merry Christmas.
Okay, that was a little intense. Maybe we should
take a seat and relax for a second...Wait,
where’s my chair? This is just a pile
of wood chips! Oh, I see, it’s SCP-1609,
the remains of a chair. What’s this doing in the
video? We’re making a video on gruesome deaths,
we don’t need a goofy pile of
wood chips throwing everything
out of-
Okay, okay, I’m sorry!
I won’t talk down to you again! I should have
remembered: When SCP-1609 feels threatened,
it teleports wood chips and metal
fragments into the lungs of its victim,
tearing them apart from within and leading
to their victims choking to death on their
own blood...Come to think of it, this probably
does deserve to be on a list of the worst deaths.
And finally, we’ve got SCP-149, also known
as the Blood Flies. To the untrained eye,
these nasty little suckers are just mosquitos.
Non-anomalous mosquitos might give you malaria
if you’re unlucky, but outside of that, the worst
thing you’ll probably get from these guys is an
itchy bite mark. That’s definitely not the case
for SCP-149. If one of these creatures bites you,
you’re infected with a retrovirus that
mutates regenerating human cells into
fertilized mosquito eggs. We’re off to a
rough start already, but it gets worse.
Within a five-hour period, the victim is covered
in large, hard cysts filled with live mosquito
larvae. By this point, they’ve reached full
maturation, and begin to exit the body en
masse - through the nose, mouth, and eye sockets.
Infection by SCP-149 is fatal, and the chance of
infection has been estimated to be 50% from one
bite. It almost has you wishing for malaria.
And there you have it, folks, some of
the most horrific ways you can die at the
hands of some of the monsters, objects,
and concepts from the SCP Foundation.
But if we’re being totally honest with you,
that’s barely even scratching the surface.
There are so many awful ways to die in the SCP
Universe, it’d be almost impossible to cover them
in one video. If you want to see more horrifying
SCP deaths, let us know down in the comments.
If, of course, you live that long...
Now go check out “Evil Monster
Created by SCP Foundation
SCP-2419 - The Laughing Men”
and “Irresistible Pick-up Artist
SCP-3512 - The More You Know” for more SCP
Foundation scenarios that’ll give you nightmares!